aujourd'hui a été remis une rapport de
la mission d'information et d'évaluation
sur l'avenir du périphérique et dans ce
rapport il ya une proposition qui est de
limiter à 50 km heure la vitesse sur le
périphérique parisien qui est
aujourd'hui de 70 km heure je vous le
rappelle la maire de paris anne hidalgo
a déjà fait savoir qu' elle trouvait que
c'était une bonne idée
c'est d'ailleurs un point de vue qui
n'est pas nouveau chez elle puisque elle
le disait déjà au début du mois sur
france inter la vocation du périph ce
n'est pas de rester une autoroute
urbaine dans les années qui viennent
donc la proposition de transformer le
périphérique en d'abord boulevards
parisiens
c'est à dire faire réduire la vitesse et
en même temps végétalisée c'est bien sûr
dans ce sens là qu'il faudra aller voilà
il faut aussi végétalisée et alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est que du côté du
gouvernement on est un peu moins
enthousiaste peut-être parce qu on se
souvient de ce boulet de la réduction de
la vitesse à 80 km h sur les routes
départementales
écoutez françois de rugy c'est le
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire ont interrogé ce matin dans la
matinale de radio classique le figaro et
lui dit doucement sur la limitation clé
ya quelques années on est déjà passé de
90 à 82 81 à 70 est ce que moi je serais
surtout pour qu'on puisse moduler la
vitesse en fonction un de l'état du
trafic
2 de l'état de la qualité de l'air après
il faut discuter de ça avec les élus
locaux
c'est pas soit la mairie de paris tout
seul soit l'état tout seul qui doit
décider de cela j'en ai déjà fait preuve
dans le passé de d'esprit d'indépendance
face à macro et ce sera une nouvelle
nuit signe là oui je sais pas si c'est
face à emmanuel macron il ya aussi
beaucoup de candidats putatifs face à la
perspective de 2020 qui sont prononcés
sur la question du périphérique même un
candidat qui apparaît même de détruire
le périphérique est de transformer
complètement
notons quand même que lorsque la la
vitesse a été abaissée de 90 à 70 km
heure il ya eu beaucoup de critiques
dans le bruit médiatique mais dans les
enquêtes faites auprès des parisiens
cette mesure a été largement saluée il
ya toujours ce décalage entre ce qu'on
peut dire des anges
e à l'oeuvre à paris est ce que disent
les parisiens et l'a très souvent il ya
une logique de contresens ou de cours de
courant on ne veut pas uniquement
réduire la vitesse à 50 km heure ce qui
est déjà une chose
elle veut par ailleurs enlevé une des
trois voies et donc réserver une voie
aux véhicules prioritaires aux véhicules
propres au covoiturage donc ça veut dire
que le trafic actuel non seulement ne
pourrait plus voulait qu'à 50 km heure
et devrait rouler que sur deux voies au
lieu de trois là je pense que les
embouteillages
aujourd'hui ce serait de la rigolade
mais on peut reprocher bien des choses
tandis que nous on peut pas lui
reprocher de manquer de cohérence
anne hidalgo là un projet elle veut
éradiquer la voiture de paris elle a
commencé par et pour celles rend la vie
impossible aux automobilistes c'est
extrêmement raisonnée elle a commencé
par le faire dans paris et maintenant le
fait autour de paris c c est le prix à
payer c'est le mécontentement des
automobilistes pas des parisiens mais
pas des parisiens d'accord et comme en
l'occurrence ceux qui vont qui vont
râler le plus et qui vont en pâtir
ce sont les banlieusards qui tourne
autour pourra pour rallier l'arrivée
d'une banlieue faire le tour et finit
par entrer dans paris
elle se dit le prix politique à payer
est absolument pour l négligeable donc
c'est un vrai projet et peut-être qu'il
peut être politiquement payant parce que
du coup on dirait que la qualité d'air
s'est améliorée sur la troisième voie
les gens font du vélo de la trottinette
que sais-je encore et et les parisiens
sont très contents alors mais on
rencontre de renforcer à paris qui sera
une espèce de 2,2 ghetto ont rejoint la
logique dont parlait tout à l'heure de
ségrégation sociale et de nick ont pris
dans le vote c'est-à-dire un ghetto de
riches
entouré par une barrière quasiment
infranchissable parce que il ya deux
moyens de rendre d'empêcher gendre dans
les villes soit on met des péages on les
fait payer soit on empêche de circuler
dans les deux cas ils entrent pas et est
donc concret et donc on aura magnifique
espace paysagé végétalisées ou des gens
en trottinette vaqueront d'une start up
et notre start up c'est sympathique
fatickois il faut il faut juste dire que
les pauvres les malades bon bah on n'a
plus besoin c'est une vision du monde
c'est pas une vision du monde ce qui est
fou c'est qu'on appelle ça le
progressisme le progrès 6 7 d'éradiquer
les pauvres il faut s'y faire
sur le figaro.fr on vous pose la
question êtes vous favorable à la
limitation de la vitesse à 50 km heure
sur les périphériques de paris et des
grandes villes puisque le débat n'est
pas uniquement pour la capitale et vous
êtes 72% à nous répondre non laurence
marchand taillade est ce que vous prenez
le périphérique est ce que vous voulez
volet moins vite
je suis banlieusarde donc je fais partie
de ces gens que anne hidalgo ne veut pas
voir dans sa ville avec nos méchants
véhicule moi ce que je constate c'est
plusieurs choses d'abord il ya eu une
première tentative pour passer de 80 70
alors les effets parce que avant de
s'interroger sur est ce que c'est bien
ou pas ou pas bien il faut quand même
savoir quels sont les effets niveau
besson baisse de la pollution zéro
rien aucun effet baisse en termes de
décibels 1,5 décibels ce n'est pas
audible au niveau de l'oreille
donc en fait les bénéfices sont proches
du néant donc effet en tout cas nul
bon ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est qu'effectivement
j'ai l'impression qu'à l'hidalgo pense
que paris est une île
sauf que paris n'est pas une île et
paris n'appartient pas au parisien il
serait temps que anne hidalgo en prenne
conscience parce qu'au lieu de
systématiquement vouloir chasser les
voitures de paris il faudrait qu'à
commence d'abord par trouver des
solutions parce que je suis désolé mais
tous les banlieusards ne peuvent pas se
déplace en trottinette tous les
banlieusards ne peuvent pas venir à
paris avec des transports en commun
parce qu'en l'occurrence aujourd'hui il
n'y a ni investissements dans les
transports en commun voilà et elle n'est
pas des responsables des transports en
commun donc il serait temps d'abord de
mettre en place des solutions pérennes
parce que il ya quand même des gens
l'échec cuisant et monumental d'autolib
qu'il faut rappeler qui est un véritable
scandale sur lequel elle s'est essuyé
les pieds en s'excusant gentiment
m'enfin ça coûte quand même des millions
1 donc il serait temps d'abord que anne
hidalgo prennent conscience que paris
n'appartient pas au parisien que les
banlieusards ne viennent pas pour
polluer me viennent pour bosser et que
c'est leur gagne-pain la gagne pain que
d'utiliser leur voiture
frédéric dabi laurence marchand taillade
dit paris n'appartient pas aux parisiens
mais ce sont les parisiens qui votent
pour
oui c'est on est tourné dans une logique
d'élections municipales j'avais été un
peu choqué par un sondage publié par le
figaro où on avait on avait interrogé
des français et des franciliens sur le
bilan dany d'al gore s'est complètement
le droit du figaro mais dans une logique
électorale à florensac c6 r c'est moi
savais pas ça n'avait pas un jour où on
interrogeait de l'est parisien
d'ailleurs je pense que si il ya en tête
le résultat des élections européennes à
paris avec la carte de paris qui est
absolument sidérantes seize
arrondissements notamment ceux de droite
qui sont dominés par l hérault m et
quatre arrondissements non pas par le ps
mais par europe ecologie les verts de
18e 19e et 20e et le on est le onzième
je crois quand même que anne hidalgo
quand elle a fait cette intervention sur
ce rapport sur benfica quand même appelé
à une large concertation avec les élus
de villes de banlieue mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya la question de la méthode qui a
fait l'objet de critiques mais je le
répète il ya un vrai décalage entre une
adhésion des parisiens y compris ceux de
droite
le segment le plus défavorable à la
politique de nintendo cédé le tiers de
parisien qui déclare avoir une
automobile à ce qu'il faut quand même
rappeler que 65% des parisiens n'ont pas
de voiture donc elle avoue si j'ose dire
la voie libre
un dernier mot laisser à nos internautes
qui témoignent de leurs difficultés à
circuler dans paris philippe je fais une
moyenne de 17 km sur cet anneau tout sur
l'a86 d'ailleurs l'a86 on le rappelle
pour les non parisiens c'est ce type de
grand périphérique qui entoure la
banlieue parisienne philippe propose de
moduler la vitesse comme en allemagne et
lino nous dit pourquoi pas 30 km heure
on a bien des zones à 30 km heure en
ville quant à philippe il est favorable
à un péage ce qui devrait rendre les
choses plus fluide et bien voilà à vous
de vous faire votre opinion
point de vue c'est fini pour ce soir
merci beaucoup
[Musique]